those nine for aaron boone will face
bruce zimmerman making his fifth start
of the year
yep and the first time uh against the
yankees first tour against the red sox a
lot of runs
got 10 the orioles scored 11 total but
while he was in 10 then it went to two
then it went to one and then trevor
rogers pitched a great game for the
marlins so again lefties hit him a
little bit that's probably why order is
hitting ninth still in the lineup
line drive and a base hit down the left
field line and that's going to go into
the corner
so lemayo who had seen his average drop
to 250 opens the game with a double
here's aaron judge
le mayhew down at second scoreless in
the first next offering is looped out to
left it's down in front of hayes phil
nevin gives this stop sign to le mayhew
at third base
as judge hit it off the end of the bet
it dropped in front of the o's left
fielder yankees have men at the corners
with one out
so the eggs have some traffic on the
bases and this guy's been their most
dependable hitter he had that big double
that looked like he was going to drive
in two runs in the eighth inning
fly ball right field
gonna be run down by mullins in right
center tagging is la mayu he'll score
it's a sac fly
for urshela and the yankees have a
one-nothing lead
the ball was away he didn't try to pull
it he went with it that's how you knock
and runs with fly balls you go to the
opposite field
so if this is a change up he may be
looking for it
well it was a change-up and it hung and
he still looked for it and then he's
going so bad he popped it up
and that lineup is gonna face the
veteran right-hander corey kluber it's
really out of character the control
issues so far for corey kluber and you
know what he's always been a slow
starter coming off the injuries that
we've talked about quite a bit so yes
his 4.01 career career era through april
and then 3.0 from may on and it might be
time to reinvent himself
1-2
swing and a miss chase the pitch out of
the zone mancini down on strikes a
really good action on that 84 mile an
hour breaking ball it's classified as
more of a curve ball here's dj stewart
here's the one two
swing and a looper out to the right side
of the infield torres backing up makes
the catch in the shift
so kluber puts together a clean bottom
of the first inning and after one it's
the yankees one of the orioles nothing
another reason to stay disciplined
castle one for four with a double
yesterday
as that double came
in the midst of a one for 28 skid the
1-0 he swings pulls it on the ground at
third or shallow stays down toss to
second one no door to first that's a
double play
and the orioles despite having two on
base after the walk and they hit by
pitch can't score
so one down down the top of the third
and aaron judge will be the batter 1-1
cut on and rip to left it high that is
far that is gone
a judging blast
he had a line drive to left and left
field in camden yards yields a lot of
home runs
so judge comes around third and here
comes the judge
as he hits home plate and the yankees
take a two-nothing lead a line drive at
camden yards on a fastball middle in
right in his wheelhouse and it gets out
in a hurry at camden
line driving to left center field it's a
base hit and mullins cannot cut it off
it goes to the wall
labor torres will stop at second with a
two two-out double akashio kind of now
controls the narrative if he hits well
he's gonna be in the lineup the next day
and then the next day
as he skies one to right field
and that ball is gone it just took off
it is gone
a home run for higashiyoka
he is two for two and the yankees lead
three nothing and if he's taking matters
in his own hands
he's doing a pretty good job and getting
higgy with it and the yankees take a
three nothing lead yes that young man
will stay in the lineup
and hagashioka's power is for real
this one's hit sharply and it's snared
by mike cal franco from his knees to
first base
to complete the out nicely done
by the orioles third baseman i mean
that's a one hopper and somehow he
snares it what do they call third base
the hot corner now here's the 0-1 to geo
and the pitch is hit hard base head left
field one run scores and coming home is
the second run and he's going to be out
by five feet
well they've got to stop running on
hayes there's no
question about it and an rbi for ashela
yo one pitch to mancini and this one
slapped by the third baseman or shella
and into left field for a base hit
mancini rounds first he's on his way to
second he'll make it their standing and
the orioles have their first hit it's a
leadoff double here in the bottom of the
fourth and moving on to third
is mancini so one down orioles have a
chance
for a run without a hit now if franco
can get him in
and he will reach out get enough of this
one muscle it to third or shella
not in time infield singled in an rbi
for franco and the o's are on the board
and you mr franco get the bonus the rbi
the base hit
now here's the 2-0 to cisco cisco the
tying run
and the pitch is swung on and grounded
to first lemayo steps on the bag and
kluber goes through six and did
absolutely a brilliant job
trailing the yankees by a 4-1 score
stan hits one deep to center field
mullen's back track
see ya a long home run off the bat of
stanton and it's 5-1 yankees a
stantonian
home run
giancarlo
no sipo
oh little spinning slider right there
smashed better calm everybody down a
little bit make them feel a little
better in that dugout i would think he
will try to win his first game in a
yankee uniform and a
pretty good performance you know pitched
a little bit into trouble out of trouble
used all his pitches a lot of strikes
kept the ball in the ballpark now here's
the 2-1
hit on the ground to second
rougey throws to first to end the inning
in the inning no runs two hits two left
how about your first strikeout in the
bigs of giancarlo stanton
[Applause]
instead of ground ball to short this
will be nice six four three it's a
double play
j flaw's first double play in the big
leagues and ryan mout castle
is going to hang on to the baseball and
toss it into the orioles dugout another
souvenir for jflo wow nice breaking ball
nice result
the wives a good pitched an inning in
the third and now litki is on the verge
of pitching one to end the game and here
is a left-hand hitter cedric mullins
and the o2 breaking ball is hit on the
ground to first le mayo to the bag in
time ball game over yankees win
yankees
win
a really important win for the yankees